All cops are bastards
tell me
something right now that the police are
good at other than whooping ass a lot of
us were asked if we could imagine a
future without police
and i answered yes to that question one
even broader idea that's gaining
momentum right now is defunding the
police
instead of abolish the police or defund
the police
how about privatize the police you know
policing is not
a marketplace you can't choose another
police force to take
care of you to watch over your
neighborhood actually private policing
is more common than most people realize
and it's a proven way of making law
enforcement more accountable to the
communities they're paid to protect
a lot of people think that law
enforcement specifically
must be provided by a monopoly
from the government but it turns out in
history and even in modern times there's
plenty of private
examples of people working to create
order and safety in society edward
stringham is the president of the
american institute for economic research
and the author of private governance
creating order and economic and social
life
if you look closely in many cases you
see
lots of private sources of order that
goes all the way
from simple things like unarmed security
guards
it goes all the way up through very
advanced sets of
private legal self-regulatory
organizations so certain places like
harvard university
mit massachusetts general hospital
have fully deputized private police
stringham also points to what happened
in san francisco during the gold rush
they actually didn't have a police force
at
all so by the late 1840s
early 1850s they started creating a
small
government police force but they were
basically
powerless and so at the same time
the private citizen said we need to
create
our own private police force in
chinatown
the government police were not very into
helping
the residents of chinatown and they also
relied
on private policing so this is something
that
is not just abstract and theoretical but
something that has been around
in san francisco since the very early
days
private governance is pervasive
it's all around us in history and in
modern times
and the better it works the less
we see it we don't police people we
protect them
police are law enforcement officers so
essentially
their task is based on negative metrics
arresting people for drugs
or violence that has already occurred
which is not protection
dale brown is the founder of detroit
threat management centers
which has been providing private
protection in the motor city since 1995.
we find ways to protect people even from
prosecution
essentially we create conditions where
no violence occurs and no prosecution
occurs
because no violence occurs detroit
threat management centers
operates as a for-profit security
company that provides bodyguards works
with homeowners associations and secures
precious cargo delivery
but it also runs an educational academy
in which graduates volunteer to provide
free security to domestic violence
victims and other vulnerable individuals
who detroit city police don't protect
we hunt predators out of the community
we deny them the opportunity
to rape rob and kill the families that's
our primary function
in 2017 detroit threat management center
employees stopped carrying guns
you really want to avoid the use of
force and violence whenever possible
it's positive it's appropriate it's
what creates a better quality of life
for everyone one of the main problems
that we see
with bureaucracy and monopoly is
a lack of concern for consumer
well-being well accountability and
responsibility
are intrinsic in the private sector we
have real-time audio and video in each
vehicle
they're actually all watching each other
while they're on duty and i train my
staff members
constantly and then you have to know law
so we constantly study the law
we go through scenarios and they're
constantly coached
into better performance so i don't have
better people
i have a system and that system is what
makes us capable we already have
more private security in various forms
in the united states than we have
government police
and we can think about ways that we can
continue to expand in that direction
for those people who are worried about
militarized or
violent police and thinking about ways
to
replace them with alternatives we don't
need to
dream up some abstract ideals and think
about how things might
be we could actually look at how private
security
how private policing already exists
draw from best practices and say look
we do have markets and we can rely
more on markets and less on a coercive
government monopoly